foreign
[Music]
Journey looks like
but first let me introduce myself
my name is Pablo I'm originally from
Spain and I moved to the Bay Area eight
years ago to work first for Facebook and
then later for Google
I moved with my family my wife I might
now teaching teenage daughter this is
asking how why the first three we went
to after the pandemic in 2021
these are my parents I just wanted to
include this picture because it reminded
me where I grew up and also it brings
some joyfulness
and this is me in 2019 an amazing year
when I run my second heart marathon and
I started with trial launch so basically
what I'm trying to say is that if you
have a good job a loving family some
hobbies and you do some exercise your
mental health is probably on track
well
it's not exactly fake it's just not the
whole story every time I heard somebody
talking about do these four or five
things and you're going to be good it
didn't resonate with me so today I'm
actually going to take you into my
mental health Journey
so
I work for two of the best companies at
the time to work for but I didn't have a
great experience
I was fighting with imposter syndrome
sorry I had anxiety but I didn't feel I
could talk about it because it was one
of the best places I was supposed to be
happy so there was a lot of pressure on
that after seven years I look for help
and the diagnosis actually surprised me
I suffer from depression
that was actually a relief because
suddenly I didn't think I was doing
something wrong I had a mental illness
and a mental illness can be treated and
not any mental illness actually I've
been suffering chronic depression since
I'm a teenager so basically my whole
adult life and I didn't know it
so let me talk about depression around
300 million people suffer from
depression in the world
is more than that doesn't underestimate
because a lot of people don't reported
it some people don't know it like it was
my case or let's not even talk how
developing countries where mental health
is not even part of the conversation
the second thing I want to bring your
attention to is that around almost nine
percent of women and around five percent
of men suffer from depression that will
be in a cohort like this with 400 people
between 30 and 40 people suffering from
depression right now and for those of
you I want to tell you that I see you
your experience is valid but I also want
to when you think about does disparity
between men and women
has a lot of extrema on it and women are
brave and talk about it even more than
men it's very difficult for men to talk
about this
the last thing I want you to pay my
attention here is about how depression
can lead to suicide and suicide is the
second leading cause of death for people
10 to 34.
10 years old
and yet
we don't talk about
about it enough
so yes this is using Hawaii but I didn't
want to go on this trip
at that time I was at my deepest on the
depression it was 2021 and I I didn't
think I was a good parent I was I was
having a lot of conflict with my
daughter
and I was repositioning some of the
mistakes my my father did that
ultimately did they make us to have a
good relationship so depression
convinced myself that they were better
off without me I wanted them to go to
the trip won't experience life without
me and I will stay behind working and
thinking how to commit suicide
now
relax I'm in the picture I went to
Hawaii I'm standing here things are kind
of working out and this is me as like
many the first people trying to use
humor to continue so let's move on
around that time I was also taking some
trainings at work and one of them remind
me of hey put your oxygen mask first
take care of yourself but yet I was
focusing on making my teams happy
productive successful and not looking at
my own experience
luckily in one of those trains also I
saw that there were other options and my
analytical thinking made me think well
if I think in our suicide there are many
other things I can do maybe I can ask
for help the last option is always there
but I cannot reverse the order so I went
online I took one survey just to see
what was going on with me I didn't know
about depression at the time and
minutes later you can imagine what I
wrote that 10 minutes later somebody was
calling me on the phone asking me how I
was doing and providing a list of eight
therapies that were taking patients at
the time and that were covered my
insurance because finding a therapist
when you are more in need is very very
difficult
so I spoke with three of those eight
people with two of them I didn't have
any connection but luckily with the
third one I had a great connection and
Michael engineer began
something like that was happening around
the time is that my mother died 11 years
ago my father three years ago at the
beginning of the pandemic
and even if I didn't have a good
relationship with him suddenly finding
myself with none of my partners made me
look at life and that from a different
perspective
but the reason I wanted to include this
picture is actually because in 2021 when
I was beginning three weeks after
starting therapy
from September 5th my father's birthday
to September 11th my mother's birthday
it was suicide prevention week and don't
ask me why but that small thing shut up
the depression voice for a while like
many other small things the smile of a
stranger on the street a song on the
radio talking with a friend talking with
you here so those things can help to
shut off the depression voice
another thing I learned during the
during therapy is that my brain doesn't
generate enough serotonin unless I'm
exercising regularly and kind of
intensively and if you don't know what
serotonin is you are very lucky you
don't have a problem with it most likely
I'm happy about you
but for me that was the issue and 2019
was an amazing year I was doing a lot
but that stopped with the pandemic now
when I asked for help and I was working
with my therapist another option came
there is medication
I could start medication and that helped
me to get out of the hole I was taking
for myself
so I want to report that this is a
genuine picture one month ago in the
black year parade in Auckland with my
family we had a great time by working on
how and feeling and my mental health my
experience and my relationship with
others have improved a lot that's not to
say hey I'm cured my depression is gone
I actually know that my depression would
won't ever be gone I would have to
continue working on it every day but now
I have a lot of tools that help me when
those shitty days happen like it just
happened two weeks ago those thoughts
are not completely gone but now I have a
toolbox if you are interested on what is
working for me that's very personal come
to John ask me afterwards
by now I just want you to remember three
things
number one as Leaders people and
organizations please take care of
yourself first
second
mental health journey is not a straight
road it's not something that happens a
couple of times it's something for your
life journey and the road is windy it
has ups and downs if you don't keep your
eyes in the road
do my crush
sorry
there sorry the third one that was too
you have to learn to count
the third one mental illness is an
illness I'm not embarrassed to be
standing here and saying I suffer from
an interest in the same way I wouldn't
say hey I broke my ankle that's okay but
you can find help you want it you can
find a therapist you can find a doctor
there's medication there's other people
so please reach out this is me to we and
this is me asking you that we should be
taking care of each other thank you
[Music]
[Applause]